bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parler brac de 45 minutes ont fait le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec atv leader qui donne
mes côtés beaux jours et dans
l'actualité cette semaine c'est une
guerre de civilisation ces mots sont
ceux de manuel valls
après les nouveaux attentats terroristes
qui ont fait réagir le premier ministre
c'est une expression aussi qui choque
certains mais dans la course après un
long suspense marine le pen s'est
finalement déclarée elle sera tête de
liste du fn dans la future région nord
pas de calais picardie pour les
régionales et puis l'hommage de la
nation à charles pasqua cérémonie aux
invalides à paris
l'ancien milieu de l'intérieur avait 88
ans 88 ans carole figure du gaullisme
pour commenter cette semaine notre
invité
malek boutih bonjour un jour vous êtes
député socialiste de l'essonne et vous
avez remis cette semaine un rapport à
manuel valls sur la génération radical
qui décrit un peu la dérive islamiste
d'une partie de la jeunesse française
rapport choc constat sévère que vous
faites sur l'action de l'état l'échec du
politique vous nous en parlerait dans un
instant je vous propose d'abord c'est la
tradition dans cette émission d'écouter
ce que pensent de vous certains de vos
collègues à l'assemblée
j'apprécie toujours assez régulièrement
emd marseille trois jours
je connais bien être fait longtemps
malécot qui il était un grand militant à
la fois des banlieues de la lutte votre
bras 6
on partage beaucoup de choses là ne
différences politiques que c'est un
homme engagé courageux qui n'hésite pas
à quelques fallait entreprendre sa
propre famille politique pour défendre
des convictions
c'est quelqu'un d'intéressant ce bon
dernier connaître je connais pas
personnellement je l'image des journées
c'est celle d'un homme politique ou
rager
assumant des positions parfois qu'ils
n'étaient pas normalement dans la digue
majoritaire de son de son parti il a osé
dire tout mon avis aux copies de
militants
justement c'est parfois
moi si j'avais une valeur à lui
attribuer un mot sans vraiment le
connaître les autres personnages hauts
risques
courage on est souvent à contre-courant
c'est bien vous ça malek boutih
non je crois pas c'est à vous non c'est
quoi je mangerai en tout cas courageux
oui on peut pas s'attribuer une vertu
comme ça mais c'est la semaine de vaud
oui mais non non moi je pense pas je
pense que je suis pas si courageux que
ça je veux dire je vais pas aller me
taper la tête contre le mur
je suis je suis plutôt modeste dans mon
approche de mon mandat est de mon action
politique
je pense que la personne doit s'effacer
derrière quand même un certain nombre de
combats donc mes qualités personnelles
elles existent peut-être un peu mais je
dois beaucoup s'il ya des équipes à des
gens je vois qu'en france il ya des gens
beaucoup plus courageux que moi je veux
dire est ce que c'est pas pareil le
débat politique
être sur le terrain se confronter les
difficultés je trouve qu'il ya que ce
soit les policiers quand dans leur
travail quotidien que ce soit un certain
nombre d'acteurs sur rov dans des tas
d'hommes de terrain avant tout je suis
un homme de terrain puis j'essaie
d'aider mon pays voilà c'est ma boutique
quand on vous a connu sa cravate qu'est
ce que ça change ma demande a remis la
cravate doit être passé côté
international kiev qui reste du
président de sos racisme façon j'ai une
continuité dans au mois quelques étés
les fonctions que j'ai occupées sur le
terrain associatif aujourd'hui en tant
que parlementaire j'essaie de garder une
certaine ligne droite c'est à dire moi
mon engagement politique il n'est pas
idéologique
j'ai des idées j'aime le débat
intellectuel mais j'ai une dette
je suis un enfant d'ouvrier né dans un
bidonville qui a eu un handicap dès sa
jeunesse il ya beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont aidé ces gens il représente la
france et la république d un style des
médecins des animateurs un peu tout et
je crois pas qu'on ait des self made man
je crois pas à la théorie que tout seul
on puisse se faire et donc je rembourse
ma petite part à la république voilà si
je peux faire ça c'est déjà pas mal à
dérouler un peu le fil de l'actualité
lundi manuel valls lui n'a pas peur des
mots
une guerre de civilisation voilà les
propos de manuel valls se prémunissent a
repris un terme utilisé aux états unis
par les faux kodjo octobre du bush
notamment pour justifier la guerre en
irak et la polémique est partie
elisa berthelot mais deux jours après
les attentats qui ont frappé la france
la tunisie et le koweït
manuel valls est à nouveau en première
ligne dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
les mots employés par le premier
ministre pour qualifier cette série
d'attentats ne sont pas choisis au
hasard ces guerres ce combat sera ce
sens passé on reconnais que l'agglo doit
durer la méthode est ce que ça veut pas
dire qu'on a déjà perdu
non nous ne pouvons pas perdre cette
guerre parce que c'est vous font une
guerre de civilisation c'est notre
société notre civilisation nos valeurs
que nous défendons guerre de
civilisation l'expression rappelle le
choc de civilisations théorisée par
l'universitaire samuel huntington est
largement reprise par george deubeuliou
bouche ou nicolas sarkozy pour la droite
manuel valls a fait preuve de lucidité
nous avons salué hier la conversion et
la lucidité du premier ministre une
forme de conversion à la lucidité parler
avec les mots qu'il convient de sujets
pour les décrire ce n'est jamais une
erreur à gauche
la formule fait polémique si le premier
secrétaire du ps a défendu ses propos
d'autres comme julien dray préfère s'en
détacher quelles sont les situations qui
sont en guerre parce que le mot guerre
de civilisation quand on le prononce
comme ça qu'on me dire quelle est la
situation avec lequel nous sommes en
guerre je sais moi qu'on pense d'eux
avait un doute
le gign ou parce que je crois pas que la
civilisation arabo musulmane est une
menace par rapport à la civilisation
judéo-chrétienne vous ne rien au travail
utiliser ça ne changeait pas utiliser
cette expression est ce que is enough
merkel et la civilisation que nous
apprend pas utiliser une formule martial
manuel valls est coutumier du fait après
les attentats de début janvier il avait
employé les termes d' apartheid social
et d'islam au fascisme des expressions
qui avait déjà fait polémique vous malek
boutih vous auriez dû utiliser cette
expression
écoutez comment on peut définir un
mouvement qui
dans tous les pays où ils mènent des
attentats ou il les présents par exemple
concentre une grande partie de ses
activités à détruire toute l'histoire
toute l'histoire les valeurs de
civilisation c'est une guerre contre la
civilisation et c'est ça qu'a voulu
exprimer le premier ministre et je
trouve que quand monsieur dray s'en est
pris au premier ministre en transformant
ses propos il rend pas service au pays
comme tous comme de l'autre côté ce
qu'il ya dans ce pays par rapport à un
sujet tu penses que ce sujet là le
premier ministre est sûrement quelqu'un
qui est le plus clairvoyant le plus en
avant et je le dis je suis pas d'accord
avec tout ce qui peut dire mais sur ce
sujet là dans l'opinion publique il a un
large soutien parce que il a une volonté
le problème c'est d'arrêter de jouer
avec les mots quand il a parlé d'
apartheid dans les banlieues il ya des
gens qui commencent à l'apartheid
mais comment on appelle des zones où il
ya tous les noirs d'un côté tous les
blancs de loot voulait dire que le
polémiste mais des mots là où certains
ne veulent permettre surtout premier
ministre veut mettre des mots pour
réveiller des consciences et je trouve
que jouer là-dessus edi rama non c'est
pas le bon mot on pour cacher en fait
l'inefficacité du travail parce que
c'est aussi pour ça que moi je me suis
engagé parce qu on est dans un pays du
blabla il y en a énormément beaucoup de
paroles sur les mots c'est pas le bon
mot c'est le juste mot mais de l'action
il y en a - et donc je pense que ceux
qui donnent des leçons premier ministre
devrait se retrousser les manches et
montrer de quoi ils sont comme ça c'est
pour eux aussi je lèverai en particulier
pour julien dray qu'un qui quand même
pas un super bilan sur cette question
alors malaguti vous avez justement été
sur le terrain rencontrer un tas
d'acteurs pour écrire votre rapport
génération radical c'est le titre vous
décrivez un échec du politique une
défaite du politique la faillite de la
république qui n'a pas su capter ces
jeunes qui ont basculé vers vous dites
un phénomène de masse c'est un rapport
alarmiste fataliste ni alarmistes ni
fataliste c'est un rapport qui politise
une question qui étaient traités que sur
l'angle culturel comment voulez vous que
les français comprennent un phénomène
qui depuis vingt ou trente ans on leur
explique que d'abord c'est un truc de
chiites en iran donc c'est pas religieux
niveau c'est non je sais du wahhabisme
qui ne comprennent pas tout ça les gens
et les musulmans eux-mêmes qui vivent en
france ne comprennent pas la manière
dont on traite le sujet est en fait
quand on a une explication beaucoup plus
structurelle on se rend compte qu'on a à
faire un mouvement politique qui
instrumentalisent
manipule réécrit une religion l'islam
mais qui a une ambition politique
extrêmement fort et qui s'appuie sur
quoi sur les failles de nos sociétés et
en particulier dans la jeunesse voilà
sans doute un vide politique qui comble
il compte quelque chose que le politique
n'a pas su capter c'est ça que vous
devez vous les politiques veulent pas su
faire il ya une responsabilité du
politique
il m il a même quelque chose sur un
point très particulier parce que la
nouvelle génération de djihadistes ceux
qui vont en ce moment en syrie ceux qui
font les troupes de l'état islamique
ils ont une particularité ce sont tous
des jeunes très jeunes
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
joueurs aussi ça veut dire que la
révolte existe dans la jeunesse et que
cette révolte soit le trouvent un
débouché dans la démocratie dans le
débat politique soit si on veut
l'étouffer elle trouvera un débouché
dans le djihadisme
et en ce moment c'est ce qui se passe
d'où le fait que vous avez beaucoup de
jeunes qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'islam et les musulmans que vous
retrouvez aujourd'hui en syrie alors
peut-être sur les prisons c'est que pour
lutter contre la radicalisation aux
prisons il faudrait peut-être créer des
quartiers c'est ce que veut faire manuel
valls la responsable aujourd'hui 2,5
s'occupe des prises au adeline hazan dit
c'est pas du tout ce qu'il faut faire
vous moi je m'en fous de préconiser quoi
dans les prés la prison est un des lieux
un des lieux de radicalisation en
particulier pour capter les petits
voyous et en faire des terrorismes c'est
ça il y en a eu le schéma de concret un
quartier spécifique
je pense qu'il faut tenter des deux
expériences je crois que plutôt que
faire une polémique et dire mais non
c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire
il serait intelligent que dans deux
maisons d'arrêt différentes
on essaie d'y observer ce phénomène
entre le regroupement le regroupement
permet aux terroristes de se coordonner
il ya des travaux layle prada mais quand
voulez quand vous voulez quand vous les
laisser éparpillées et recrute donc où
est la bonne mesure je pense que dans
consensus malek boutih deux tests non
c'est à dire il faut avoir une approche
pragmatique ça suffit de polémiquer sur
la moindre mesure c'est comme ça tout
est paralysé en france les en fait le
monde politique sur ce sujet je vais
vous dire une chose comme d'autres
d'autres sujets les gens ne pensaient
pas qu'ils n'ont pas d'idées mais ils
n'osent rien dire parce que vous êtes
tout de suite au tribunal à
l'inquisition
ah mais non mais tu n'as pas le droit
c'est une peur de s'exprimer pour
contente pas d expérience pourquoi dans
deux maisons d'arrêt différentes
on entend pas un truc on l'obtient pour
qu'on fait pas une enquête un peu à
l'étranger comme on veut travail quel
résultat ça donne voilà il faut avoir
une pratique et pragmatique wim sous mon
point de vue maintenant je suis pas du
tout un spécialiste
prison même si la plus grande prison
leurs actions alors qu'avec mesure on va
avancer on va parler de la disparition
de charles pasqua décédé à l'âge de 88
ans personnalités politiques personnages
forts en gueule réaction très nombreuses
un peu partout écouter puis je suis très
peiné du décès de charles pasqua
c'est un gaulliste intransigeant
toujours fidèle à ses idées c'est un
homme avec un talent d'orateur qui va
nous manquer personne ne parlait comme
charles pasqua
il était à la fois très moderne et en
même temps on avait toujours
l'impression de voir un film en noir et
blanc 86 et la loi devaquet c'est malik
oussékine c'est un certain nombre de
choses je sais bien qu'il ya une part de
lumière et d'ombré dans chaque homme
mais je voulais aussi ça mais c'est part
de lumière
le choix de la france le choix de la
résistance était quelque chose de
fondamental d'un personnage comme
charles pasqua peut-être de fait un
personnage très controversé qui lui-même
et met d'ailleurs faire des polémiques
et des controverses
on peut que saluer son engagement très
jeunes dans la résistance
à 15 ans c'est suffisamment rare pour
être souligné après sur le reste de son
action politique comprendrez que nous
écologistes
ne trouvions pas beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels nous pourrions salué son action
puisque de fait nous étions en
opposition avec lui sur tous les sujets
et von al-haq boutique que retenez-vous
de l'homme charles pasqua il ya un
principe on combat les vivants mais on
respecte les gens décédés
chez comme militant dé sera sifflée
combattu charles pasqua et franchement
il était sans pitié avec nous et très
dur mais je pense que effectivement au
moment de son décès il ya un respect à
avoir comme tout le monde l'a dit son
action de choix le choix de la
résistance
et puis quand même quand même faut
mettre les choses au point sagem était
un dictateur
on aime on n'a jamais été enfermé mis
dans des combats dans des prisons donc
il faut relativiser les propos et je
pense que en tout cas moi il me reste
une chose c'est que c'est un des rares
année dernière homme politique d'une
génération où passait pas par l'ena des
grandes écoles pour faire une grande
carrière politique
le mec était chez ricard est il devenu
un héros ayant fait aussi partie de mes
cheveux passé chez ricains peut-être pas
ce mardi va parler du front national ça
y est c'est fait c'était pas vraiment un
mystère mais marine le pen se lance
finalement dans la course aux réflexions
régionales elle mènera la liste dans le
nord pas de calais mari la bat qui pour
diriger la future grande région nord pas
de calais picardie depuis hier et
l'annoncé de la candidature de marine le
pen conduirait cette bataille pour les
élections régionales
les spéculations vont bon train les
coups de gueule aussi à la candidature
de la fille de jean-marie le pen dans
notre région est un non événement madame
le pen connaît très mal cette région
qu'elle ne voit qu'à travers la vitre du
thalys lorsque
elle part de paris pour aller à
bruxelles chercher ses indemnités de
parlementaire européen
à droite c'est xavier bertrand qui
mènera le combat mais à gauche même si
pierre de saintignon est officiellement
le candidat du parti socialiste
certains doutent qu'il fasse le poids
face à deux personnalités politiques
d'envergure nationale père de saintignon
et le candidat du parti socialiste qui
doit rassembler toute la gauche
ça va être très très difficile
ça sera très très difficile et les
sondages semblent malheureusement
indiqué qu il sort en difficulté dans
les couloirs de l'assemblée
certains socialistes vont même jusqu'à
faire planer la menace d'un appel à la
candidature de martine aubry pour
contrecarrer marine le pen non sens pour
françois lamy soutien de pierre de
saintignon les députés proches de la
maire de lille
ces parlementaires qui épouse qui pour
l'instant d'ailleurs sont anonymes
à ma connaissance ce ne sont pas des
amis de martine aubry vous l'aurez
remarqué
donc je doute un petit peu de leur
volonté de faire que la gauche gagne et
je pense que c'est pas le jour pour se
diviser le jour aujourd'hui ce que
l'objectif c'est le rassemblement
pour l'heure un nouveau sondage donne
marine le pen gagnante loin devant
xavier bertrand et pierre de saintignon
bon c'était pas vraiment une surprise
mais elle part au combat quand même
marine le pen vous en pensez quoi
sincèrement l'intérêt de cette élection
on dit qu'un sondage qui le donne
gagnant en fin de reportage
l'intérêt de l'élection régionale est-ce
qu'il la lecture politique intéressante
de cette élection dans le nord là où
marine le pen sera présente
c'est qu'est ce qui va se passer entre
les deux tours mais est-ce que s'il ya
un vrai danger que le front national
prenne cette région est ce qui aura un
réflexe républicain ou pas on sait pas
grand-chose à la grotte bah oui on sait
pas encore de tiercé mais est ce que il
y aura ce front républicain ou pas en
tout cas moi j'appelle les partis
républicains le mien oui comme les
républicains une réflexion si on laisse
une telle région dans les mains de
marine le pen
alors ce sera son bras sa base de
conquête du pouvoir dans tout pays vous
y réfléchir dès vous y croyez ou sem
phases de conquête de tout le pays oui
bien sûr ouais ya le risque produit
c'est même moi je pense que vous sentez
vraiment oui bien sûr mais vous pensez
qu'il ya que cet appel n'a peut être
entendu
et pas si peut être entendu mais
l'impression qu'il ya une vraie fracture
vous pensez que c'est encore possible
je pense que tout est possible je pense
que la politique elle dépend aussi des
choix d'individus de leurs
responsabilités et en particulier des
chefs de partis y auront à se décider
pour la gauche ça aussi parce qu'il ya
quand même un succès mois mais bien sûr
c'est valable pour la couche avons
peut-être quand même sur le père jean
marie le pen qui revient au front
national qui garde la vice-présidence
grâce à une action en justice
ça vous donne quels sentiments tout cela
ce qui me fera beaucoup dans l'actualité
je dirais périphériques du front
national on entend parler de mise en
examen pour du financement politique
on entend parler de mise en examen pour
avoir planqué de l'argent en suisse on
voit un déchirement familial et ça n'a
aucun impact dans jugement des électeurs
dans les instituts de sondage
et donc ça prouve quelque chose ça
prouve que ce n'est pas le programme du
front national qu'il le fait émerger
c'est que le front national est vraiment
le thermomètre d'une crise politique et
morale en france extrêmement important
en fait le front national c'est une
sorte de virtualité pour les français
qu'ils utilisent pour condamner le reste
du monde politique
d'un certain point de vue le front
national pour est un marteau pour taper
c'est pas vraiment mobile se pressent
dans les affaires familiales
quoi qu'il se passe et c'est ça aussi ça
doit être lu et compris pour ce que
c'est c'est d'ailleurs c'est ça qui vous
fait penser qu'en 2017 il ya risque mais
bien sûr parce que je pense que le
changement
j'ai entendu des gens dire ouais
maintenant les gens s'intéressent au
programme du front national sauf qu'il
ya un problème ils n'ont pas de
programme c'est vérifiable sur internet
ça c'est le talon d'achille de le banc
de programmes non pas du tout parce que
s'il avait un programme
il pourrait pas gagner des élections
c'est une machine à fantasmes et le
front national aujourd'hui devenu un
outil de contestation du système
politique
alors mardi toujours bernard cazeneuve
veut donner de nouveaux droits aux
étrangers tout en luttant contre la
fraude et la dévoiler un second projet
de loi devant les députés réunis en
commission
en pleine crise des migrants le texte
fait polémique explications de rim
benameur audition très attendue pour
bernard cazeneuve intégration mobilité
des talons et lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine
voilà les trois axes de sa loi sur le
droit des étrangers
parmi les mesures phares des titres de
séjour pluriannuels du
validité de deux à quatre ans après un
premier titre d'un an
pour bernard cazeneuve il s'agit de
simplifier la vie des migrants
nous soumettons les étrangers qui
viennent en france un véritable parcours
administratif du combattant nous
soumettons des centaines de milliers
d'étrangers à près d'une dizaine de
passages en préfecture par an comment
s'intégrer
lorsque l'on court de titre précaire en
titre précaire
autre volet l'intégration renforcement
du niveau de langue demander aux
étrangers avec la possibilité de suivre
des cours création d'un passeport talent
un titre de séjour unique pour les
étrangers qualifiés et simplification du
passage du statut d'étudiant à celui de
travailleur c'est l' équilibre que le
gouvernement propose dans le projet de
loi
favoriser l'intégration des étrangers
qui ont vocation et qui sont sur notre
territoire qui ont vocation à y rester
sur le long terme et être ferme et
efficace dans l'éloignement des
étrangers qui ont se sont vu refuser
l'autorisation de rester sur notre
territoire cette année qu'il faut
respecter
dernier volet très critiqué la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière
le projet de loi veut favoriser
l'assignation à résidence pour les
sans-papiers en attente d'expulsion au
lieu de la rétention administrative
bernard cazeneuve défend des expulsions
plus rapide un étranger en situation
irrégulière et cela doit être dit et
assumée doit être reconduits à la
frontière et les filières criminelles de
l'immigration clandestine
ces réseaux de passeurs qui tirent
profit de la mort ou de l'exploitation
des plus vulnérables doivent être
démantelées l'examen du texte est prévu
le 20 juillet dans l'hémicycle il
rencontrera à la fois l'opposition de
l'extrême gauche et celle de la droite
qui le juge insuffisant
est-ce que mal à goûter avec ce texte le
gouvernement à trouver le bon équilibre
entre la lutte contre
l'émigration clandestine et la
nécessaire sécurisation du territoire
qu'est ce que vous comprenez dans ce
texte je comprends beaucoup de nous dire
ce que la particularité de bernard
cazeneuve
c'est qu'il a toujours une approche
pragmatique des sujets et au lieu de se
laisser enfermer dans le débat
idéologique il avance regardez comme il
l'a dit il à traiter un problème que
tout le monde connaît les préfectures la
machinerie administrative le problème
des expulsions sont toujours qui amène à
quoi qui amène que petit à petit en
france on va comprendre une chose j'en
ai parlé il ya dix ans un peu plus de
dix heureux il va falloir se doter d'une
politique d'immigration en amont c'est à
dire pas sur le territoire
mais avant que les gens arrivent sur
territoire ça réglera pas tous les
problèmes mais ça permettrait peut-être
que au lieu d'avoir une administration
et une gestion surchargé sur le
territoire ce soit en amont deuxièmement
il faut créer une règle priorité doit
être donnée aux étrangers qui sont
honnêtes qui respecte notre pays et qui
ont envie d'être en adhésion aux valeurs
françaises plutôt que de dire à ta pas
le bout de papier je te renvois moi je
préférerais qu'on dise voilà toi tu
respecte les droits de la femme tu es
d'accord avec la laïcité à droite face à
110 ans et plus tôt que les critères
aussi de d'intégration culturelle au
pays doivent être mises en avant que
vous avez parlé il ya une dizaine
d'années mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il ya
une révolution des mentalités pas après
pas les choses finissent par avance et
béret la réalité finit toujours par
revenir sur le tapis
alors on va passer à la loupe du scan du
bien à ces nous a rejoint d'autres
partenaires des figaro la loupe gym
jarrassé du scan vous pouvez prendre
d'autres partenaires on va bien sûr
revenir quelques mots quand même sur le
rapport que d'autres invités a commis
bonjour malaguti vous avez donc remis
cette semaine un rapport sur la
radicalisation djihadistes des jeunes à
manuel valls on a vu beaucoup de
réactions soient temps déjà sur sur ce
rapport et notamment des réactions qui
viennent de la droite on a vu bruno le
maire frédéric lefebvre roger karoutchi
même christine boutin il vous félicite
tous unanimement pour ce rapport est ce
que vous êtes surpris satisfait par ces
par ses réactions venues des rangs de la
droite
j'espère qu'ils ont lu parce que moi
telle chose qui est sûre que je sais pas
c'est comme c'est comme des livres qui
sont pas encore sortis on dit qu'ils
sont vos minables
non mais je suis sensible évidemment
sont des gens respectables intelligent
qui joue un rôle important
à droite républicaine donc je sais pas
mais sincèrement je pense que je n'ai
pas écrit pour moi vraiment je pense que
chacun doit s'inspirer lire et c'est pas
la vérité que j'ai donné un angle de vue
et il faut le lire il faut voir pas
simplement le constat mais aussi des
solutions que je préconise parce que si
on est d'accord sur un constat mais
qu'on fait rien ça ne sert à rien ça va
peut-être vous choqué malek boutih vous
êtes souvent applaudi sur votre droite
et non sur votre gauche
pourtant je suis élu par des agréments
de gauche donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que parfois sur un certain nombre
de sujets la fracture droite gauche elle
n'est pas là où on pense est ce que ça
veut dire par exemple que la gauche a du
mal encore à accéder à cette libération
de la parole que vous appelez de vos
voeux
cette absence de non-dits dont vous êtes
le symbole
on a vu par exemple martine aubry
critiqué manuel valls sur cette
expression dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure guerre de civilisation est ce
que la gauche encore sa révolution
culturelle à faire sur ce sujet là selon
vous mais la droite et la gauche une
révolution culturelle à faire la droite
est enfermé dans une posture
autoritariste on refuse tout et malgré
les avancées sur la diversité allait
quand même à chaque fois dans des débats
incroyable par exemple servir du port à
l'école sincèrement ce n'est pas d'un
niveau de débat présidentiel et la
gauche elle a aussi des difficultés à
aller et je pense que les deux grandes
formations politiques républicaines
doivent comprendre une chose
il s'agit plus d'un sujet de polémique
mais un sujet aujourd'hui de sauvegarde
de l'identité républicaine d'avenir pour
notre pays et de force pour notre pays
comprendre que toutes ces questions là
soient elles sont un problème soit
devient un avantage que vous souhaitez
que le ps se saisissent de votre rapport
et il donne son avis de façon très
claire
écoutez d'abord j'ai jeu j'exposerai une
partie de mon travail aux universités
d'été à la fin du mois d'août david
assouline qui est responsable de ça ma
mamma invités on en a discuté dès ce
matin jean christophe cambadélis a mis
sur pied une commission à l'intérieur du
ps donc de toute façon compte tenu je
dirais de la percussion de l'actualité
des dangers je pense que le parti
socialiste comme les républicains vont
devoir travailler sur le fond et faire
évoluer leur torpeur parlons un peu de
françois hollande il ya quelques
semaines dans une interview au parisien
vous disiez il n'arrive pas à
communiquer avec la banlieue il reste
très années 80
si vous aviez un conseil un symbole que
pourraient mettre en oeuvre françois
hollande pourrait il réussir à
recréer un lien avec les jeunes de
banlieue ce serait quoi je voudrais vous
préciser une chose comme quoi les a
priori sont durs dans mon rapport je
parle pas que des jeunes de banlieue
voyez par exemple je parle de la
jeunesse rurale ya aussi dans ce pays on
parle on parle jamais du petit français
blue qui vit dans un village et car rien
comme à venir aujourd'hui avoir 20 ans
dans un village savoir sa vie finit à 20
ans mais vous voyez eux
aujourd'hui ils sont un des grand nombre
de gens qui vont jihad et comme quoi il
faut avancer donc j'ai pas de conseils
mois donné au président de la république
je suis pas un conseilleur je crois que
il est avisé
j'ai fait un travail il est aujourd'hui
la mise à la disposition tout le monde
il ya d'autres gens qui font des
propositions simplement je pense que je
pense que le monde politique en général
doit être interpellée sur une chose
c'est pas la question c'est pas de
trouver un gadget mais se relever les
manches et de comprendre que ce sujet
vraiment j'insiste sur ce point là on va
rentrer dans la présidentielle
c'est un moment de faiblesse pour nous
on peut être attaqué dans cette période
si jamais on montre des divisions face à
nos ennemis
alors on ouvrira une brèche c'est le
moment de créer un consensus républicain
sur une chose appelé à l'union sur ce
sujet sur ce sujet je pense qu'on peut
polémiquer débattre mais une fois qu'on
s'est mis d'accord il faut il faut
prendre un axe et dire aux autres que
même si en alternance on changera pas
les polynies sont nécessairement
commencera une cible en vue de 2010 est
encore plus forte qu'aujourd'hui
potentiellement la france est une cible
particulière vous savez pourquoi
à cause de la laïcité à cause du fait
que les musulmans sont extrêmement libre
en france c'est le musulman en france
ils ont beaucoup plus de liberté que
dans plein de pays musulmans officiel la
france c'est le contre exemple des
djihadistes en termes de démocratie pour
eux à la limite il ya d'autres pays
il ya assez de caricatures mais la
france c'est un fait c'est vraiment un
pays qui par son modèle républicain par
la laïcité est le contre-exemple donc
oui effectivement on l'a vu on et cibler
est particulièrement ciblée alors on a
beaucoup parlé des mots parlons un peu
des actes êtes vous pour la fermeture
des mosquées salafistes comme l'a
réclamé le front national est comme le
sambre laissé entendre désormais le
gouvernement a priori ça c'est une
voilà c'est une mesure qui pourrait être
mise en oeuvre c'est compliqué à mettre
en oeuvre
c'est d'autant plus compliqué que l'on
sait pas ce que c'est qu'une mosquée
salaf il faut déjà défini si tout d'un
coup on dit qu'il ya un lieu qui
organise le terrorisme en france et
combien il faut pas le faire mais alors
je comprendrais rien mais la vérité
c'est qu'elle est le piège que nous
tombent les extrémistes et les radicaux
s'équipent ou 6 pouces pour essayer de
créer des punitions collectives et à
partir de punition collective créée des
réactions c'est une stratégie issus des
guérillas gauchistes action réaction et
se protéger derrière les innocents donc
si vous devez fermer une mosquée faut
prendre garde que tous les gens qui
soient dans cette mosquée le vivent pas
comme étant une punition pour eux donc
je préfère l'action que mène le ministre
l'intérieur
ici les imams radicaux on cible les
genres a dit qu est ce qu on doit taper
et par contre on doit protéger les
musulmans honnête intégré et puis adhère
aux valeurs de la république m'avait la
question dernière question pour ce
rapport vous avez consulté énormément de
gens on l'a vu on l'a dit parmi eux jean
paul ney c'est un journaliste que vous
présentait aussi comme un des éducateurs
juste la semaine dernière après
l'attentât en dans l'isère il faisait un
tweet il disait il faut enfermer
préventivement toutes les personnes
fichées s comme l'était yassine salhi le
suspect de l'attentât
il est temps de taper dans le tas est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ses
expressions un peu radical absolument
pas mais j'ai auditionné beaucoup
beaucoup de gens avec qui je suis en
total désaccord mais aussi si vous
faites un rapport en écoutant que les
gens qui sont d'accord avec vous c'est
formidable mais moi j'ai écouté des gens
que j'ai trouvé hallucinant dans leurs
propos mais pourquoi lui alors
mais parce que il a pris contact et que
nous disons qu'il avait des choses à
dire et pourquoi pas et j'ai écouté ce
qu'il avait à dire
mais ces deux si on filtre à l'avance
voilà et ça veut pas dire ces gens là
ont influencé mon rapport mais j'ai
écouté tout le monde j'ai écouté le
front national jeunesse j'ai écouté les
jeunesses socialistes
j'écoutais les jeunesses ouvrières
chrétiennes et j'ai 30 ans d'expérience
sur le terrain donc je pense que ceux
qui lisent un cas écouter un pelt est
diabolisé sincèrement je suis pas
sensible à ça je suis pas sentie fameux
vous dites quand même
manuel valls françois hollande et les
autres ses fessiers vous de ce rapport
et les gros temps mais moi je pense que
le premier ministre
c'est ce qui fait il m'a confié un
rapport il savait déjà et va agir
maintenant
moi j'ai une grande confiance dans sa
dette
me nation sur ce sujet il a il a quand
même une ligne de conduite je le dis
sincèrement il a une ligne de conduite
qui a été très importante pour l'unité
du pays voilà très bien et bien merci
jimpo semaine prochaine et on va
poursuivre avec un autre dossier très
différents la grèce qui est toujours à
la une et l'europe peut-être sur le
point de basculer en zone inconnue
la situation financière de la grèce
casse tête des européens entre athènes
et ses partenaires le dialogue ne passe
plus et la france n'est même plus sur la
même longueur d'onde que l'allemagne
la zone euro est elle entrée en terra
incognita c'est ce que croit savoir
françois hollande est à des lieues des
positions avec mounir souci alexis
tsipras se joue la carte du peuple face
aux institutions européennes
le premier ministre a annoncé
aujourd'hui que son référendum était
maintenu selon lui c'est le seul moyen
de pression efficace pour négocier et
obtenir des concessions de lieux le nom
n'est pas simplement un slogan le nom
est une étape décisive pour un meilleur
accord que nous espérons signer
directement après les résultats de
dimanche
jusqu'à cette date les discussions sont
suspendues avec les partenaires de la
zone euro qui souhaite attendre le
résultat du référendum
la journée a laissé apparaître une
faille dans le couple franco allemand
françois hollande appelant à trouver un
accord dans les plus brefs délais
quand angela merkel préféré attendre le
verdict des urnes la grèce qui n'a pas
remboursé un milliard et demi d'euros au
fmi est actuellement défaut de paiement
la nouvelle n'a pas fait trembler les
marchés financiers quoi qu'il se passe
en grèce je suis convaincu que la zone
euro va pouvoir y résister aujourd'hui
le gouvernement grec a rouvert les
banques uniquement retraités autorisée à
retirer seulement 120 euros par personne
cette crise grecque c'est l'échec
d'abord l'échec de la grèce où d'abord
celle de la gouvernance européenne
abbas est d'abord l'échec de la grèce je
veux dire c'est pas la gouvernance
européenne qui a trafiqué les comptes
qui ont été remis à l'union européenne
c'est les gouvernements grecs c'est
l'échec de partis politiques grecs qui
main dans la main on partager le magot
européen au lieu de développer leurs
prix c'est l'échec d'un pays qui laisse
ses milliardaires ne pas payer d'impôts
parce que moi je suis solidaire des
pauvres grecs
oui ce n'est pas de tous les grecs donc
c'est à bord de cette supra ce pardon
aux corbeaux du gouvernement le
gouvernement qui a été lue sur cette
crise syriza et le gouvernement actuel
on voit bien ce qui se passe il sait ce
qui ne veut pas mais c'est parce qu'il
veut et c'est bien le problème
il a été élu sur un refus et pas sur un
programme d'où d'ailleurs le caractère
très improvisés de sa démarche très
improvisés il négocie mais c'est pas et
on a l'impression que aujourd'hui c'est
une démonstration que il suffit pas dans
une crise de montrer ce qui va pas il
faut être capable d'apporter des
solutions et l'impasse dans lequel le
gouvernement aujourd'hui grec c'est
qu'il n'a pas de solutions
il a des refus mais la patrie b alors et
justement les européens on a
l'impression qu'ils ne veulent pas voir
ce qui se passe ils refusent d'accorder
un crédit à ce qu'il demande sur
notamment sur la dette parce que tout le
monde sait que la grèce ne remboursera
jamais sa dette est ce que les européens
sont aussi responsables mêmes de ce qui
se passe parce qu'ils n'offrent pas de
solution la grèce prenons une hypothèse
on accepte les revendications de la
grèce et restent dans la zone euro etc
et puis demain c'est un le pays qui fait
la même chose et puis demain c'est un
autre pays qui fait la même chose qu'on
finit donc la grèce de servir d'exemple
nom doit pas servir d'exemple mais elle
doit pas servir non plus de contre
exemple c'est à dire que et c'est là où
je d'ailleurs j'ai une différence
d'approché avec les analyses qui disent
que le couple franco-allemand que la
position d'angela merkel et de françois
hollande serait si divergents
je suis pas sûr parce qu'il faut dans le
même sens qu'ils avaient commandé un peu
c'est une expression de séries
télévisées il ya un peu bad cop
goudkov oui je pense que l'allemagne
joue un rôle de pression que la france
joue un rôle d'adhésion mais je crois
que le moteur franco-allemand essaye de
gérer cette crise avec conscience parce
que ce dont il est question c'est y a qu
une seule question que les gens doivent
se poser dans le monde actuel si on se
passe de l'union européenne où va-t-on
et l'autre chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que parmi les forces qui
soutiennent la grèce on retrouve toutes
les forces nationalistes tous les anti
européens
déguisé en justicier ah les pauvres
retraite mais qui demande qu'une chose
tu es l'europe et donc en ce moment il
ya un grand débat politique entre les
forces nationalistes qui monte est ce
qui reste des forces européennes ça
c'est un autre risque de grippe grave
crise politique en europe en vue c'est
ça que vous dites pas dans les 24 heures
mais indéniablement si il y avait un
échec sur la question grèce une machine
en sera lui mais qui pourrait désagréger
laurent paquin pardonnez-moi de revient
sur internet avec une nationale et
politique françois hollande on dit que
la position qu'il pensait aussi parce
qu'il a des vues sur 2017 et pour
agréger un petit peu toute la gauche pas
faire de mécontents
c'est vrai je crois pas du tout non pas
du tout c'est pas le style de françois
hollande ils ont peu la synthèse c'est
son psy mais il n'est pas dans une
position de synthèse là sur cette
affaire comme françois hollande
les débuts de sa vie politique c'est lé
club témoin avec jacques delors l'union
européenne et c'est une question pour
lui c'est peut-être pour l'une des
questions les plus structurants tu
penses que il se sent dans ce débat
européen a une responsabilité
particulière par rapport à d'autres
dirigeants européens
elle va passer au jeudi on va parler
totalement d'autres choses sur les
allocations familiales
un nouveau régime pour les allocations
familiales elles sont désormais modulée
en fonction du revenu pour certains ça
montre et pour d'autres évidemment ça
baisse regarde tout cela peut-être
avez-vous reçu ce sms ce matin ou
peut-être un autre si vos allocations
familiales vont baisser
aujourd'hui entre en vigueur la
modulation de cette prestation en
fonction du revenu
une famille de deux enfants qui gagnent
plus de 5600 euros net par mois verra
ses allocations divisé par deux après un
autre seuil de 7500 euros mensuels les
allocations sont divisées par quatre
nous maintenons l'universalité des
allocations familiales et coûtera
continuer à percevoir des allocations
familiales
mais la justice monsieur le député la
justice c'est que les familles qui ont
moins reçoivent plus
et à partir d'aujourd'hui nous mettons
en place une réforme de justice de
modulation des allocations familiales
les allocations ne seront plus uniforme
mais resteront touché par tous les
femmes seules les plus pauvres verront
leurs allocations augmenté mais la
mesure est surtout destiné à dégager 800
millions d'euros d'économies dès 2016
environ 1 foyer sur dix est concerné par
cette baisse des allocations familiales
cela correspond à 500 mille familles la
perte est en moyenne 227 euros par mois
pour les ménages concernés
cela peut aller jusqu'à une perte de
4000 euros annuels pour une famille qui
en gagnent 9000 par mois pour les
ménages les plus aisés cette diminution
fait suite à la baisse du quotient
familial depuis 2012 avec guti mesure de
justice mesure symbole de gauche symbole
non mais symbolique non non c'est une
mesure d'âge d'ajustement en particulier
parce que qu'on parle beaucoup de ceux
qui vont perdre de l'argent les foyers à
plus de 5000 euros etc
mais on parle pas de ceux qui vont en
gagner et il ya un volet qui est très
important c'est ce qu'on appelle les
familles monoparentales qui est un mot
qui cache les femmes seules parce que
c'est 99 % des femmes qui voulaient le
voir un peu de revenus supplémentaires
et aujourd'hui dans mon rapport j'en
parle
une des raisons pour laquelle on a
beaucoup de problèmes dans la société
française et dans la jeunesse il ya
énormément de divorce et énormément de
femmes abandonnées avec leurs enfants
on retrouve des des choses sur le
terrain social et dans les quartiers
populaires qu'on avait oublié un peu et
cette politique elle vise quand même un
peu à aider ces femmes en difficulté est
par ailleurs j'ai pas vu à ce jour mais
j'attends de voir une famille qui
viennent neuf mille balles par mois
venir se plaindre d'avoir perdu un peu
de ses allocations familiales je crois
qu'ils n'oseront pas je pense que les
gens sont beaucoup plus raisonnables
qu'on pense que c'est une réforme qui va
passer extrêmement facilement dans le
pays en fait désormais allocations
familiales sont modulés en fonction du
revenu mais quelque part c'est quand
même un coup porté aux principes
d'universalité et c'est pas grave pour
vous vous dites c'était nécessaire voyez
bien c'est tout mon approche de la vie
politique française
le débat le théâtre des principes avril
fille on peut avoir des principes il
faut avoir des principes il faut avoir
des références mais quand tout vous
diriger un pays il faut être un peu
pragmatique et s'occuper du réel
et arrêtez de s'enfermer dans à chaque
fois des diatribes et des théâtres qui
ne veulent plus rien dire voilà le
principe des allocations familiales
sincèrement ça veut rien dire ce qu'il
était les personnes qui touchent ce
revenu mais je vous dire une chose
pourquoi elle était universel parce
qu'avant les femmes de bourgeoise n'avez
pas le droit de travailler
est ce une manière de protéger les
femmes de bourgeois quand le bourgeois
la laisser tomber
elle avait un minimum de revenus voilà
la vérité ce n'est pas un prince ça peut
dépasser ce principe oui parce que
maintenant elle se débrouille mieux
alors malagoli de leur ire en politique
ne plaît pas forcément à tout le monde
les guignols serait peut-être relayé aux
archives l'emblématique programmes de
canal+ est menacé de disparition écouter
ses réactions
je suis très triste parce que c'est
je suis un enfant des guignols comme
beaucoup de politiques de ma génération
les guignols de l'info c'est c'est
l'histoire de ces trente dernières
années avec des coups de griffes
incroyable sur notamment les politiques
mais je pense que
d'une 30 ans sans doute qu'il faut se
renouveler aussi mais c'est avec
beaucoup de tristesse que je veux voir
disparaître ces marionnettes qui nous
énormément rire je n'arrive pas y croire
une seule seconde ça me paraît tellement
hallucinant voilà pour toute une
génération on y est extrêmement attaché
pour l'instant on va se battre mais
pendant que politique en tant que
citoyen pour pour regarder cette
émission qui semble déplaire donc à
monsieur bolloré mais il faut tout de
suite faire une marianne pour monsieur
bolloré
je pense que nous nous serons un grand
nombre à nous mobiliser en disant
vraiment avant de prendre une telle
décision il faut il faut en mesurer les
contours et pour ma part en tout cas je
considérer ça comme vraiment extrêmement
de match mais est-ce que cet os que les
politiques ont raison de se mêler de ça
de cette es20 propriétaire d'une chaîne
de télévision peut décider de ces
programmes
mais il ya quand même moi un symbole qui
me gêne c'est l'année on a tué charlie
on tue la deuxième émission la plus
connue de caricatures et de droit à la
caricature des caricatures et là des
gens qui portent aux nues le droit à la
caricature mais qui font disparaître
juste dans les 24 heures après la mort
d'alain de greef une émission symbolique
ils ont droit de le faire mais le timing
la méthode choisie c'est pas très propre
vaut mieux assumer les choses en face et
est donc je pense que il est normal à
partir de ce moment là qu'un certain
nombre d'acteurs publics disait c'est
pas très juste françois hollande a réagi
en disant la caricature fait partie du
patrimoine ça c'est ben oui mais c'est
exactement ce qu'on a tous dit au mois
de janvier
cc on a une particularité vous savez
tout le monde était solidaire de nous
pendant les attentats mais il ya des
pays très puissant les états unis où
tout le monde a eu les jetons de publier
des caricatures
ils ont peur voilà nous on n'a pas peur
on est la république donc on va pas se
mettre avoir peur des guignols c'est
pourtant afin d'amener pas de bébé et
encore plus maintenant
d'accord je connais la légende on pense
que jacques chirac il a été élu grâce
aux guignols mais la vérité est en fait
un personnage populaire met d'accord je
vais vous dire il était populaire parce
qu'il était populaire c'est pas par les
guignols qui l'ont rendu populaire il a
su évoluer travailler moi je pense que
c'est souvent comme ça et vous en êtes
témoin la presse les médias sont souvent
les boucs émissaires d d d d
incompétence politique voilà moi je suis
pour la séparation des choses très net
il doit y avoir une liberté
et protéger la liberté est ce que
j'espère c'est que si canal + se passe
des guignols il ya peut-être une chaîne
pourquoi pas la télévision publique
france télévisions s'est positionné bras
c'est pas c'est pas bête c'est
intelligent de la part du service public
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
action d'un président de chêne président
d'un grand groupe qui peut décider comme
ça de supprimer mais quelque chose de
très populaire l'action va le nommer de
monsieur bolloré d'ailleurs donc
décideurs ça ça vous choque ça surtout
ce qui est formidable c'est que c'est un
payeur minoritaires devenu décideurs
majorité oui c'est à vous de voir
le capitalisme est un jeu à plusieurs
mende ce que pour vous c'est la fin du
rire la fin de la caricature en
politique en france
si le pays la gauloiserie on n'a pas
fini de rire en france sincèrement
malgré les censures je pense pas moi je
pense pas du tout je pense que c'est un
pays qui a suivi au corps une motion de
la liberté ii de briser des tabous
on n'est pas près de finir de rire en
france j'en suis certain donc vous êtes
optimiste mais j'ai toujours été
optimiste sur ce pays sinon je serais
parti comme d'autres mais pas comme ça
vous a tenté un jour de partir en même
pas en rêve
franchement non non j'aime beaucoup les
autres pays moi je suis très
internationaliste j'aimerais beaucoup
travailler après mon mandat de député
sur l'afrique mais j'ai quand même la
chance de vivre dans le pays le plus
visité du monde il doit bien y avoir une
raison
merci beaucoup malek boutih
recentralisation
on se retrouve nous la semaine prochaine
bonne semaine à tous les fidèles aux
chaînes parlementaires la traviata